these are the places are culture and as a
journalist populism extremist cinemas
abbott as well as the swimmer in
europe probably germany and france
can develop a common
position but of course we only have
an agreement if all 26 others also
take part
siegrist because how often woodward in fact in  new
york the french had to move for a long time
in the matter of sovereignty but the germans
also have to
move in their fixation solely on
the debt problem and
monetary stability something happened at vw which
requires urgent clarification but
please don't use this fact
to do that  to damn the automobile as a whole,
so to speak, and thus
to create thousands upon thousands of jobs in europe when turkey in jordan
lebanon partly poor countries are
able to offer shelter to millions of people
fleeing the civil war one has to
make this effort even in this rich europe
and we need courage we must
also tell them that they cannot
stay with us so that we can really
help those who actually
need our protection from war and persecution
americans in afghanistan